commission des finances non
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
quelques considérations de méthode et
d'organisation
tout d'abord puis et quelques
préoccupations ou observations sur le
fond nous nous inscrivons dans le cadre
de l'application de la loi organique sur
les lois de finances celle ci va
atteindre dans quelques mois son dixième
anniversaire et le débat sur les
prélèvements obligatoires est née de ce
texte
plus exactement de son article 52
à l'époque il s'agissait
c'était la volonté conjointe des
commissions des affaires sociales et des
finances d'entamer le processus
budgétaire annuel par un éclairage
global sur les recettes de l'état et de
la sécurité sociale nous observons année
après année qu'il n'est plus possible
d'avoir une opinion sur nos finances
publiques sans mettre côte à côte sans
examiner du même regard et avec la même
exigence
les deux lois financières annuelles et
parmi les propositions d'amélioration
issus du groupe que préside est il ya
quelques mois le gouverneur michel
camdessus figurait notamment le souhait
de rapprocher les parties recettes de la
loi de finances et de la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
nous n'y sommes pas encore mais
certainement cher monsieur le ministre
nous y viendront ensuite
s'agissant de la loi organique
lambert migaud si je puis est ainsi
rappeler son existence
il y figurait à l'article 50 pour la
première fois dans notre législation
le principe de programmation
pluriannuelle des finances publiques
et nous voici arrivés au rendez vous au
rendez-vous de la cohérence entre d'une
part notre langage externe nos
engagements vis-à-vis de l'union
européenne et d'autre part notre langage
interne c'est à dire les textes que nous
votons et qui sont censés organiser le
financement de nos services publics
dès lors la lolf jalons utile est devenu
un jalon dépasser très nettement dépassé
par l'évolution des choses et la crise
économique et financière a donné un
singulier coup d'accélérateur à cet
égard j'allais dire un réel coup de
vieux à cette excellente loi organique
sur les lois de finances dès 2008 la
constitution avait été révisée pour
prévoir des lois de programmation des
finances publiques
celle ci monsieur le ministre et la
seconde de la série et j'espère pour ma
part qu'il n'y en aura pas de troisième
ou plus exactement que la troisième sera
une véritable lois cadres pluriannuelles
des finances publiques ayant une force
juridique supérieure à celle des lois
financières annuelles
nous avons un réel besoin d'outils
contraignant pour servir la crédibilité
de notre trajectoire de redressement des
finances publiques ministre françois
baroin a rappelé l'ampleur des efforts
indispensables quand nous regardons
monsieur le ministre et c'était notre
exercice ce matin au sein de la
commission des finances
la perspective a commencé par l'année
2011 avec le déroulement des charges
financières pour les années à venir
quand nous observons que depuis un
certain nombre d'années et jusqu'à
maintenant ces charges financières
intérêts et remboursement de la dette
fluctuait dans une bande comprise entre
35 et 40 milliards d'euros et que d'ici
peu sous deux ans l'ordre de grandeur de
ses charges financières va se situer
dans la zone des 55 milliards d'euros
quand nous visualisons cette courbe et
ces chiffres nous observons toute la
distance à parcourir
quand nous observons la courbe du
déficit primaire qui selon la
perspective associée à la loi de
programmation qui nous est soumise la
courbe de ce déficit primaire qui ne
s'annulent ray qu'à la fin de l'année
2013 au moment même où nous
respecterions la norme des 3 %
nous pouvons constater et que l'ampleur
de notre dette
l'ampleur de l'effet volume est le
risque de taux très significatif que
porte cette dette vont être des
variables
déterminante mes chers collègues pour
tous nos comportements politiques et
pour définir l'avenir à moyen terme de
ce pays que nous le voulions ou non ces
chiffres s'impose et s'imposeront à nous
et dès maintenant dès l'année 2011 des
efforts très significatifs des efforts
structurels très significatifs vont
devoir être faits pour nous rapprocher
d'un chemin crédible de convergence la
commission des finances du sénat a
vraiment joué le jeu de cet exercice
monsieur le ministre et le président
arthuis et moi même nous sommes
passionnés pour les travaux de la
commission camdessus il ya quelques mois
tant et si bien que nous avons apporté
une contribution écrite qui figure en
annexe du présent rapport sur la loi de
programmation contributions écrites ou
nous insistions sur deux règles au-delà
des enjeux juridiques voire au delà de
la mise au point d'une révision
constitutionnelle deux raids la règle de
sincérité d'une part et la règle de
responsabilité d'autre part par règles
de sincérité nous entendions nous
entendons la nécessité de bâtir les
trajectoires en fonction des hypothèses
économiques prudentes vous y souscrivent
et mes jeux j'observe que vous y
souscrivent et voilà la règle de
responsabilité ensuite par règles de
responsabilité
nous voulons dire que les gouvernements
ne doivent être rendues responsables que
de ce qu'il maîtrise
or que maîtrise t-il le niveau des
dépenses qu'elles soient budgétaire ou
fiscales finalement peu importe ce
détail est par ailleurs les mesures
nouvelles en recettes
selon le principe de responsabilité un
gouvernement doit être tenu pour
responsable de tout cela mais rien que
de cela et si l'on veut s'assurer c'est
notre conception des choses que la règle
de responsabilité soient bien respectées
dans son esprit il faut qu'il y est un
dispositif d'ajustement et que selon des
règles de niveau constitutionnel le
conseil constitutionnel lui-même un jour
puisse être larbitre de du bon ordre des
choses en matière budgétaire et en
particulier de la conformité des lois
financières annuelles à une loi-cadre
pluriannuelle des finances publiques
votre projet de loi monsieur le ministre
va assurément dans le bon sens mais bien
des conditions le foot encore les
raisonnements que nous pouvons faire en
la matière
tout d'abord et il est nécessaire que la
loi de programmation pluriannuelle
s'exprime en termes intelligible que le
lecteur attentif puisse le comprendre et
c'est pourquoi nous sommes attachés à ce
que les normes de dépenses
à l'exception de celle relative à la
sécurité sociale soit exprimées en
milliards d'euros constants sur une base
annuelle plutôt qu'en pourcentage
d'augmentation moyen
sur une séquence pluriannuel comme le
disait mon excellent prédécesseur alain
lambert c'est une chose que j'ai retenue
je ne vais pas faire mes courses et pour
les payer en millièmes de point deux
pipes la monnaie que l'on utilise et
celle qui doit figurer dans le texte
et c'est le cas depuis les amendements
votés par la commission des finances
c'est bien en termes de normes de
dépenses
des chiffres en milliards d'euros
constants sur une base annuelle
vous avez bien voulu accepter ces
amendements monsieur le ministre il
clarifie le texte et le rendront plus
opératoire de la même façon nous avons
salué votre initiative d'interdire enfin
le recours à l'emprunt par les
opérateurs de l'état nous avons
considéré que ce principe doit être
poussée jusqu'à son terme c'est à dire
que cette règle devait être permanente
mais bien entendu l'édifice que nous
nous efforçons de bâtir avec un maximum
de dépenses pour l'ensemble des
administrations publiques d'un côté un
minimum de recettes de l'autre cet
édifice ne tiendras et ne sera
harmonieux que si l'ensemble des acteurs
joue bien son rôle jusqu'à la révision
constitutionnelle le respect de la
trajectoire reposera sur
l'autodiscipline
en ce qui concerne les crédits
d'émission et déjà pour 2011
il importe monsieur le ministre que vous
soyez totalement convaincant vis-à-vis
de vos de vos collègues et que les
gestionnaires ministériel de ces crédits
s'approprie en quelque sorte la loi de
programmation qu'il la considère comme
sans véritablement de portée
contraignante et c'est là qu'intervient
aussi le contexte économique
comme vous le savez pour la commission
des finances et c'est une conviction que
nous exprimons de longue date le taux de
croissance ne se proclame pas le taux de
croissance s'observe une fois que
l'année est passée
d'où notre souci de prudence et c'est
pourquoi nous avons souhaité qu'un
scénario alternatif bâti sur la base du
taux de croissance potentielle de
l'économie 2% par an puisse permettre de
mieux concrétiser le raisonnement de la
loi de programmation pluriannuelle
j'ai compris monsieur le ministre et
nous reprendrons ce point à l'occasion
de l'examen de votre amendement que vous
acceptiez le principe de l'alternative
que vous nous disiez que pour vous
l'obligation essentielle est de parvenir
aux 3% et que dans l'hypothèse où les
circonstances économiques et la
croissance serait un peu moins ou
sensiblement moins favorable des efforts
supplémentaires seraient faits vous nous
dites qu'il serait fait pour un volume
annuel de 4 à 6 milliards d'euros par
réduction des dépenses budgétaires
dépenses fiscales et niches sociales et
que par ailleurs vous seriez attentifs
aux effets éventuels de la situation de
l'emploi sur d'autres paramètres et par
exemple sur le déséquilibre financier du
régime de l'assurance chômage
l'amendement que vous proposez montre
que nous nous rencontrons dans le
raisonnement
même si ce n'est pas dans la
présentation du dispositif lui-même de
la loi mais c'est un raisonnement que
nous pouvons partager ce qui me
semble-t-il nous permet de constater de
notre côté aussi que ce dialogue est
particulièrement fructueux absolument
mais si les prévisions doivent être
révisées toutes conséquences en seront
tirées nous dites vous sachant que
l'impératif c'est 3%
non pas pour le plaisir de respecter un
engagement international mais en
fonction de l'analyse que nous faisons
des risques financiers qui pèsent sur
nous et aussi en nous assigne ans comme
but en 2013 ce qui est encore assez loin
de supprimer le déficit primaire et donc
de faire cesser l'augmentation de la
dette ne l'oublions pas mes chers
collègues quand on parle de 3%
ce n'est pas satisfaire une bureaucratie
anonyme
c'est tout simplement faire en sorte que
le capital de la dette n'augmente plus
ce n'est pas plus ce n'est pas moins
alors maintenant j'en termine avec cette
question du programme de stabilité
nous le savons bien cette séquence
pluriannuel qui doit dorénavant être
explicité au printemps dans le cadre de
la nouvelle procédure dite du semestre
européen
nous savons que cette séquence
pluriannuel émanant de l'exécutif et de
ses services sera transmise au parlement
pour nous il ne s'agit pas d'une
information
il ne s'agit pas d'une vague
associations il s'agit de partager la
responsabilité des chiffres et on ne
peut le faire qu'après débat et vote car
une assemblée parlementaire ne sais pas
faire autre chose que débattre et voter
ce n'est pas un colloque ce n'est pas un
lieu de recherche universitaire
c'est un lieu où l'on prend des
responsabilités et on ne peut prendre de
responsabilités que par un vote
bien entendu l'imagination est grande en
matière de procédure parlementaire et il
existe notamment depuis la dernière
révision constitutionnelle des modalités
permettant à un tel vote de s'exprimer
de manière claire sans pour autant que
l'on doivent s'astreindre à tous le
formalisme de la loi ce qui je voue la
corde ne seraient pas possibles dans le
laps de temps qu'il faudrait respecter
mes chers collègues
la période que nous allons vivre d'ici
la fin de l'année avec nos textes
financiers nous permettra certainement
de mieux prendre la mesure des efforts
qui nous sont proposés de la réalité de
ces efforts de nous convaincre de la
nécessité de ne pas diverger par rapport
à la trajectoire qui est tracé et de
considérer que notre pays ne pourra
vraiment pesé en europe et peser un
moment décisif pour la définition de la
politique économique et monétaire de
l'europe que s'il apparaît que toute son
énergie est vraiment rassembler ramasser
pour réduire les déséquilibres que nous
supportons aujourd'hui c'est une
question en effet d'indépendance
vous l'avez dit monsieur le ministre il
ne faut pas hésiter à le répéter en même
temps que de confiance confiance dans
les perspectives économiques et qu'ils
sont devant nous avec un tel déficit et
une telle dette
la confiance bien sûr est difficile à
obtenir mais c'est des efforts que vous
menez
que celle ci pourra sans doute naître ou
renaître
merci de votre attention merci monsieur
le rapporteur général
la parole est à monsieur alain vasselle
rapporteur général de la commission des
affaires sociales
madame la présidente je lui lis mes
chers collègues vers l'autre sert
aujourd'hui est de lever le lever de
rideau des débats annuel sur les textes
financiers
c'est un débat que nous estimons niveau
de la commission des affaires sociales
comme essentiel car il fournit un cadre
indispensable à nos prises de position
des prochaines semaines rappelle que
c'est la deuxième fois que nous
examinons un projet de loi de
programmation mais sans doute la
première ou d'exercice se fait d'une
manière aussi approfondi en effet la
première expérience était arrivé de
manière un peu précipité puisque je vous
rappelle c'était quelques semaines après
le vote de la révision constitutionnelle
du 23 juillet 2008 qui a institué cette
nouvelle catégorie de lois et surtout
ceux ci s'étaient produits au moment
même de la survenue de la crise
financière qui a bouleversé tous les
équilibres sa deuxième exercice ça
serait donc dans un contexte différent
celui de l'après crise et c'est dans ce
cadre que le parlement ait conduit à a
trouvé par un vote
la stratégie du gouvernement en matière
de finances publiques peut considérer
que c'est un réel progrès car auparavant
la stratégie était élaboré du seul fait
du gouvernement à l'occasion de la
transmission au début de mois de
décembre du programme de stabilité à la
commission européenne
la prose globale que cette nouvelle
catégorie de lois nous permet d'avoir
des comptes publics en intégrant les
finances de l'état celle de la sécurité
sociale et celles de nos collectivités
locales dans un même ensemble on les
insérant dans une perspective
pluriannuel m'apparaît également une
incontestable avancé jusque là au terme
de débats généraux nous pouvions
seulement discuter de l'évolution des
prélèvements obligatoires que nous avons
fait l'année dernière à la même époque
est ce que nous faisons à nouveau cette
année en même temps que ce projet de loi
c'est évidemment un exercice qui était
utile car il permettait à débat
d'ensemble mais ne conserver qu'un
aspect du sujet celui des recettes pour
les dépenses la réflexion était renvoyé
aux projets de l'oiseau projet de loi de
financement en matière sociale toutefois
je me rappelle de chaque collège nous
avions déjà ce débat et nous avions
devant c'est ce que le gouvernement
nous invite à faire aujourd'hui puisque
depuis le vote de la loi organique du 2
août 2005 le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale était
à chaque fois accompagnée d'une annexe b
qui comportait qui comporte une
projection pour les quatre années à
venir à la fois pour les recettes et
pour les dépenses à la fois pour le
régime général mais également l'enfant
de résumer obligatoire de valve nous
avons beaucoup critiqué en son temps
cette annexe que nous trouvions un
suffisamment fourni et s'il fallait en
faire un bilan aujourd'hui je dirais que
malgré ses limites notamment table de
fiabilité durabilité des projections
alain vey le mérite incontestable
d'exister de proposer une trajectoire et
de faire apparaître des tendances qui
montrait avec beaucoup de clarté les
difficultés du redressement des comptes
avec ce projet de loi que nous examinons
au moment présent
nous disposons donc d'un outil beaucoup
plus complet encore et plus cohérents et
un outil de bonne gouvernance l'outil
qui manquait que nombre d'entre vous
appelez d'ailleurs de ses voeux il
permet des carrés de façon beaucoup plus
visible et plus transparente débat
public sur l'ensemble des finances c'est
à dire sur un ensemble qui représente
veulent rappelle quand même environ la
moitié de la richesse nationale ce
projet doivent se rappeler également
n'est qu'une programmation
cela signifie que les prérogatives de
législateurs financiers comme celle du
législateur sociale son frère réservés
de même que les domaines respectifs des
deux lois de finances cette situation
pourrait toutefois évoluer si le
gouvernement retenait la proposition du
rapport comme cam déçu ce dont tu as
parlé il ya quelques instants notre
rapporteur général philippe marini de
créer une nouvelle catégorie de lois
il propose en effet dans son rapport
d'instituer des lois cadres de
programmation des finances publiques qui
s'imposerait juridiquement aux lois de
finances ou le contrôle du conseil
constitutionnel
alors certes nous n'y sommes pas encore
mais j'ai retenu que le premier ministre
avait suggéré de lancer une consultation
sur une éventuelle réforme en profondeur
du pilotage des finances publiques
allant parfois jusqu'à l'introduction
dans la constitution d'une règle
d'équilibré des finances publiques
je sais que ceci a fait l'objet
de nombreux débats à l'assemblée
nationale et notamment d'interventions
musclées de la part du groupe centriste
ce débat nécessitent à l'évidence mais
si reconnaît d'une réflexion approfondie
et l'expérience des deux dernières
années et singulièrement du premier
projet de loi de programmation doit il
me semble nous rendent particulièrement
prudent en la matière
la loi de programmation d'il y a deux
ans a été votée dans un contexte très
particulier celui de la crise financière
venait de se déclarer et ses
conséquences sur l'économie réelle était
encore très incertaine et la pertinence
de l'exercice a été très vite remise en
question
la trajectoire prévue est donc devenu
immédiatement caduque à l'époque le
gouvernement ayant fait le choix d'une
part de laisser jouer le libre jeu des
stabilisateurs automatiques et d'autre
part de mettre en place un plan de
relance significatif les déficits et la
dette publics se sont alors envolé vers
me des montants encore jamais atteint
avions nous et le gouvernement et le
président d'un public d'autre solution
je n'en suis pas certain puisque
aujourd'hui les sites nous démontre que
d'enfants la situation tend à
s'améliorer malgré tout il importe peu
chers collègues désormais de remédier à
ces déséquilibres budgétaires et
financiers considérables connaître
d'autres pays et de remettre nos comptes
publiques sur une trajectoire de
désendettement qui soit à la fois
crédible et efficace d'exercice est
naturellement bien plus complexe qu'il
n'était il ya deux ans
l'objectif qui était affichée par le
président de la république lors des
conférences nationales des finances
publiques et qui ont été repris dans le
dernier programme de stabilité présenté
à nos partenaires européens et de
réduire le déficit public à 3 fois du
pib en 2013
à l'horizon 2011 l'objectif considéré
comme majeur attend gb de six points
et pour ce faire le gouvernement vous
l'avez constaté retient plusieurs
principes il estime d'abord que les fins
de redressement doit engager l'ensemble
des administrations publiques l'état la
sécurité sociale les collectivités deux
cas c'était effectivement indispensable
mais moi je m'interroge au passage
monsieur le ministre ce qui concerne les
collectivités locales vous allez trouver
une solution qui est de reconduire le
niveau des dotations aux collectivités
locales au même niveau que celle des
années antérieures
mais comment allez vous procéder pour
obtenir de la part de nos collectivités
locales la maîtrise de l'évolution de
leur fiscalité de leur endettement
moi je serais curieux de voir comment
vous allez pouvoir imposer ça à des
collectivités qui bénéficie
constitutionnellement de leur libre
administration mais peut être avons nous
un pouvoir au niveau donc des
contraintes budgétaires
j'attends ça avec impatience parce que
autant nous sommes avec vous en charge
de la maîtrise des dépenses publiques à
travers les lois de finances et des lois
de financement pour les collectivités
locales ça sera sans doute un petit peu
plus compliqué enfin nous jugeons
nécessaire des instruments de
gouvernance des finances publiques qui
en particulier chez nos voisins
européens ont joué un rôle essentiel
pour infléchir les tendances c'est une
nécessité j reviendrons dans un instant
en parlant de l'ondam le rapport qui a
été annexé au projet de loi assez
détaillé d'ailleurs précise de contexte
macro-économique les hypothèses retenue
pour encadrer la programmation pour ce
qui est des finances sociales puisque
c'est pour stable celui-là au pupitre
les principales mairies potel
macroéconomiques à retenir sur les
suivants alors le gouvernement table sur
un redressement progressif de la
croissance pour la période 2010-2011
avec des taux progressif de 1.5 et de
deux points puis un peu plus dynamique
avec un taux moyen de 2.5 à partir de
vous venez de suivre le début des débats
sur les finances publiques pour 2011 à
2014 tout de suite preuve par trois
michel grossiord reçoit ce soir chantal
jouanno la secrétaire d'état à
l'écologie et pour suivre toute
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
il ya toujours notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne soirée sur notre chaîne
mais ce qu'il sait